Good morning, John. Last week I was in Amsterdam and as usual when I go someplace that is not my home, I'm struck
by all of the little differences like all the bikes and the trains and the trams where in my town
almost everybody gets around by car. It's easy to
say that this is a question of circumstance
and of course it is.
In Amsterdam, it's dense the roads are old and narrow and the country is flat and isn't covered in snow
half the year, like it is here in Montana but it's
also a question of choice.
Individuals making decisions in establishing and following norms. In Amsterdam, even if it's faster to take a bus, even if it's raining and gross, people
still bike because that's what you do, and since so many people do ,everything is built for bikes and trams and trains.
While I imagine trying to find parking would be a miserable terrible disaster. I don't actually know though, how these
norms get established. I imagine that they are things that just fit, things that simply make sense to the people
who have come together to make a place. Norms that, make them feel good and
valued and healthy and satisfied. The blending of story into place, into groups that's the thing that I thought a lot
about this year at Vidcon EU because it's also the story of online communities which is what Vidcon ultimately is about. At
Vidcon EU this year
We weren't able to have a fan component for a bunch of reasons that I'll put on the screen right now if you're curious.
But it was still able to be that kind of cultural exploration, we get a chance to ask
where our ideas come from what stories, we are telling to ourselves and to each other and whether they're
good stories. Having the community there I think makes that even better which is why I came
away, from Vidcon EU so excited for Anaheim and Australia later this year. I'm working on what I think are
some pretty, good speeches for those Vidcon's about defining success and some of the strategies that I find really work
when trying to figure out what kind of content is going to get attention
and be successful but, also not be bad for the people watching it. I'm excited about
My panels and also to do an old-school
acoustic set to close out the whole event in Anaheim. I guess being a founder has its
advantages. I'm really proud of Vidcon. Proud of people, who take their stories seriously and who let
Them change and become messy and complex. A couple of weeks ago on our new
Podcast, Delete This, Katherine and i were talking about how, the messiness of stories can
make it hard to love something a hundred percent but, maybe loving something 100 percent isn't right. Maybe it starts with
joy, and ends with joy but joy that
also has care and concern and thought mixed in and if we're not doing it that way, I don't even know
if that's right, which is why I love Vidcon and also why I love my new podcast where Catherine reviews
my twitter feed and if you, want to find out more about those things there's links
and maybe even some coupon codes in the description.
Any opportunity to examine the stories I tell myself is something I want more of in my life.
Taking an hour every week to go through my twitter feed with someone who cares about
me a lot is a great way to do that and so is traveling to a new place and making a bunch of cool
time-lapse videos. And so is getting together to celebrate and contemplate with a bunch of people
who care about, love and are excited about and also worried about a lot of the same things as me
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.